it was just sort of a thing where you
know all my friends were like let's go
do recruitment and I was like okay and
[Music]
actually I actually didn't want to join
a sorority I've had trouble keeping
girlfriends just as platonic friends I
grew up with sisters and brothers and I
wanted to find something that was that
kind of community I guess I was out when
I joined yeah I I don't think I was ever
like particularly closeted cuz uh I was
lucky enough to go to a high school that
was pretty accepting I was not out about
my sexuality but I've always been open
about like sex in general before I went
to my specific sororities open house in
rush I went to other ones where there
was like girly and one way of kind of
living and I was like that's not me like
I need a spectrum going into the rush
process it wasn't a huge concern of mine
because I could kind of figured if
people aren't gonna accept me for who I
am then I don't want to be part of a
sorority I knew one girl she was out in
my society but that doesn't mean that
people won't talk about you behind
closed doors just because you're there
open and accepting in the moment so it
does kind of scare me sometimes you
don't know what kind of situations
you're going to walk into one of the
first people in the sorority that I came
out to was one of my close friends it
was just like wow okay had all these
questions and she's like so how does
that work like how does sex work I
remember being in this moment and it was
part of when we were playing ten fingers
and someone asked like oh has anybody
ever done something with a girl and like
me and his other girl put our fingers
out at the same time and I was like wait
what you and it made us so close and we
found something where we're like
connected on and it's it's something
crazy and cool and like unexpected you
have a particularly high volume of like
LGBT members I don't know if it's
because like my sorta just tends to
foster that like whole be yourself
acceptance five it's not really about
what people say it's how you put
yourself out there and I'm going to put
myself out there strong and this is Who
I am and I'm not going to take
[ __ ] from no one I mean my sword is
definitely had sister save each other
before de it's not a big deal at all in
fact like we had you know a couple
sisters who graduated a few years ago
who were like we're like the power
couple of our sorority and they dated
for like three years and we're still
together and they're like beautiful and
everyone loves them I definitely find it
a little bit ridiculous when people like
fear bisexuals or fear like lesbians and
sororities because I'm like no offense
but like just because we're gay doesn't
mean we don't want standards I think
that being LGBT in my case bisexual in
the society is just another fact of life
I'm going to be this serious pledge
mistress in some ways I'm a little bit
hesitant like what if some of these
girls want to join but they're not
comfortable with me being openly out and
bisexual but at the same time like they
need to know what they're getting into
and I'm proud and I'm proud to be in a
society and I'm also proud to be part of
this LGBT community so if you want to be
a part of it I say do it I'm gonna be
happier with the choices I've made and
the people I've grown close to honestly
like your safety and your mental health
and your happiness comes first so make
sure you're safe situation and please if
they try to hate you your lifestyle and
the people you love she'd never hold you
back on something on anything in the
world and especially something that's
supposed to give you family
[Music]